[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the anime
culture corner
we've got another episode of attack on
titan season four and episode two was a
lot different from episode one which was
full of action
episode two is basically setting up the
plot for the rest of the season where we
go from here
that the final plan to invade and
recapture paradise island will commence
once again in an attempt to restore the
power of marley and reclaim the founding
titan
but just as important as well and
probably more interesting to most people
was that we finally know the name and
location of the last titan shifter
the warhammer titan in this video i'll
break down the key points of this
episode and what we can look forward to
after
but first if you like attack on titan
anime or manga in general make sure to
hit that subscribe button
i post every two to three days and if
you enjoy the content i'd appreciate the
support for my growing channel
enjoy the video this episode paid a lot
of attention to reiner especially
focusing on the regret and ptsd like
symptoms he has from his time on the
island
we see that there's clear tension
between reiner and galliard
galliard is the brother marcel who was
the jaw titan who went with annie
bertholdt and reiner to the island all
those years ago
the one who was eaten by yamir it was
also seen that galliod wanted to inherit
the armored titan back then as well
so along with the fact that reiner is
pretty much responsible for marcel's
death i can see why there's beef between
them
i also love the dinner scene rainer was
describing the iconic sasha potato scene
like it was a horror movie
it shows how marlene's and even the
titan shifters like rhinos have twisted
history to frame the
aldeans especially the islanders as
devils as pure evil incarnate
but through it all it seems like reiner
just wants the fighting to stop
he's almost scared tormented by the idea
of returning to the island at the end of
the episode
and tells falco who also shares the
desire to stop fighting to save gabby
reiner's cousin from the fate of being a
titan shifter reiner's lost all of his
friends
berthold marcel the survey corps he
knows better than anyone just how
terrible the fate of a titan shifter can
be
granted as we see the suicide of an
aldean troop and the ptsd that many of
them face
being a normal alden soldier is probably
a lot worse
i mean at least reiner isn't being
thrown off a plane in a body bag
the separation between aldians and
marlene's is clearer than ever
seeing that even the titan shifters the
highest class of eldians
have no privacy when explaining the plan
to recapture paradise island
the separated train cars having to ask
for permission to speak
even if they regain the founding titan
it seems that aldians will never become
anything more than tools for marley
unless something drastic is done of
course now before getting to the meat of
this episode the reveal of the warhammer
titan and the plan involving the tiber
family i'm gonna mention a few key
points you may have missed or just
glanced over
no one seems to know that zeke has royal
blood even including cults who will
inherit the beast titan from
an interesting but not very relevant
detail was that the kart titan
seemed to be in her titan form for two
months before this episode that's crazy
we've never seen a titan maintain their
form for so long so longevity and the
ability to sustain the form for extended
periods of time is probably the kart
titan's main power since we haven't been
made fully aware of it yet
and lastly out of the 32 ships sent to
paradise island zero returned
it seems like marlins are under the
assumption that the ships were destroyed
but i think it's very possible and
likely that the survey corps instead
took these ships
it would allow them a way to invade
marley since we know they didn't have
ships at the end of season 3
which is even more reason to believe
that the survey corps have already
invaded marley along with the fact that
we saw someone who was likely gene at
the end of last episode
and now the tiger family they're said to
have been the family that pressured king
fritz onto the island in the first place
and thus holds respect on the continent
for being anti-islander
they also have the last titan shifter
the warhammer titan
i guess i can see why it's named that
marley intends to use the tiger family's
reputation to remind the world of how
dangerous the islanders are
and spurn support for the plan to
recapture the island the driving force
of the plan
while maintaining marley's status in the
world is also to guarantee the safety of
eldians
as without the need for titan shifters
they are worthless demoralians
the moment that titans can't win the war
the aliens are no longer needed
there's a lot of tension between the
titan shifters and the marlins
i'm interested to see how it'll turn out
and if any of these titan shifters in
marley end up switching sides in some
way
especially if the survey corps come and
start fighting for the freedom of
aldeans
but other than all that this episode
wasn't that huge it was certainly
interesting and gave a lot of context
into the life that eldins live in marley
reinforcing just how horrible it is
and the fact that even though they just
won against someone they're already
preparing once again to go into war
again
the cycle of violence the sentiment that
history repeats itself is showing once
again
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth attack on titan anime
manga and character analyses
you